My name is Marina Abramović
and I'm a performance artist.
The treasures shown here
are so delicate and precious
you can't actually touch them
with your hands.
You can't turn the pages.
You don't have direct contact to them
because they are all on view behind glass.
The main point for me was
to give the public access to the treasures
in a different way.
Abramović Method is a collection
of many, many exercises
that I've learned for myself in
order to help me to actually push
my mental and physical limits.
So I give the public tools
to have this experience,
and to see what they can do with that
in their own life.
Technology becomes something that
retook our private time
so for me it's very important
essentially in this experiment,
Abramović Method,
that you leave your watch,
and you leave your computer
behind you, before you
enter the treasure place.
Because that's the way, how you
actually gain time for yourself
and you gain freedom from technology.
Here, you find beds and chairs
built into the walls.
You put on headphones,
and use a device
to actually choose the book
you want to listen to.
Very secluded.
Very private.
Without looking at your watch,
without looking at your telephone.
Just you
and the treasures.